sunday afternoon in hong kong
police and protesters now well-versed
in each other's tactics this time the
focus
was chanwan a large residential area in
kowloon
17 kilometers from the central business
district
confusing and frightening for people
trying to get home
[Music]
this woman was wrestled to the ground
after a violent confrontation with
police
the protesters principal demand is for
the government to formally withdraw
a contentious extradition bill that has
now morphed
into a wider campaign for political
reform
a campaign that has so far failed
we want the uh the chief executive
officer in hong kong to respond us
but do you really believe that you can
win at the end of the day because so far
you haven't
we should have a hope yeah because every
hong kong people
want me to achieve this goal tear gas
was again used and police drew firearms
and fired warning shots
and in a new first for hong kong water
cannon was used
as the night wore on the protesters
split into smaller groups
eventually dispersing but the violence
later spread to other areas
there were a number of arrests three
months after this protest movement began
the protesters don't seem to be flagging
and neither does the police's
determination
to suppress the movement and if anything
the police tactics are now hardening
[Music]
a tropical downpour didn't deter a
protest
by families of the police they say the
protests are taking their toll
at a peaceful gathering though some were
also critical of the force
urging restraint over the use of tear
gas
and rubber bullets that restraint
is now being tested adrian brown al
jazeera hong kong